en el vídeo pasado teníamos un lindo
condominio en 1995 en el cual cinco
familias compran casa verdad en 100 mil
pesos y bueno déjame aclarar que puede
ser que más personas quisieran comprar
casa en esa época pero no era tan fácil
porque tenías que tener ciertos
requisitos para que te para que te
otorgarán una hipoteca tenías que
realmente demostrar que podía pagar
eventualmente bueno entonces transcurrió
el tiempo transcurrió el tiempo llegamos
a 2005 este cuate tuvo que vender su
casa la vendió en un millón de pesos
aumentó tanto el precio porque había
personas que estaban empezando a hacer
instrumentos financieros basados en
hipotecas y entonces los precios de las
casas aumentaron mucho porque aumentó la
demanda gracias a que ahora las
hipotecas sean los bastante más
relajadas entonces después de esta venta
todos los del condominio empezaron a
pensar que su casa valía un millón de
pesos un millón de pesos
un millón un millón pero luego lo que
sucedió es que transcurrió el tiempo y
déjame bajar para ponerlo digamos de
este lado transcurrió el tiempo y en
2008 en 2008 este cuate de acá no pudo
pagar no pudo pagar su hipoteca
entonces se ejecuta la hipoteca le voy a
poner aquí se ejecuta q está la hipoteca
la hipoteca con esto el banco subasta la
casa y digamos que la pudo vender bueno
habíamos dicho verdad que la vendió en
300 mil pesos ok entonces había pasado
esto verdad en el inter y en el entre
qué pasa esto y esto estas personas de
acá habían pedido algunos préstamos
respaldados en su casa habían pedido 500
mil pesos así que podemos pensar que
para 2008 tienen más o menos 500 mil en
deuda verdad porque tenían estos 500 mil
más como 80 mil que debían de acá como
ya pagaron un poquito digamos que pasa
el tiempo todavía deben como 500 mil
entonces esta venta los preocupa un poco
pero de todas formas están tranquilos
dicen sabes que estás acá se vendió con
un mucho
es un cuate que pagaba muy mal el banco
tuvo que ofertar lo muy rápido y la
subasta fue muy apresurada entonces esto
no fue una transacción real vamos a
tranquilizarnos y vamos a esperar a que
los precios suban otra vez ok
pasa el tiempo pasa el tiempo y pasa el
tiempo y supongamos que ahora llegamos a
2009 esto de acá va a ser el año 2009 y
sin el cuate de acá arriba el de la casa
número 2 tiene que vender su casa así
tiene que venderla ya sea porque no se
se tiene que mudar o no se puede ser que
lo despidieran en su trabajo entonces ve
que ya no va a poder pagar la hipoteca
cómodamente entonces realmente intenta
venderlo baa los periódicos va con
agentes inmobiliarios se esfuerza
muchísimo para vender su casa en 600 mil
en 600 mil que pues parecería ser fácil
porque cuestan un millón pero no lo
logra
dicen esto está muy mal bueno dice bueno
que no la pude vender entonces como no
la pude vender no amarito la voy a
intentar vender al descubierto va al
banco y se lo llevan con la puedo vender
al descubierto al menos digamos en 450
mil y el banco dice no bueno estoy
vender al descubierto quiere decir que
va con el banco acuerda un cierto precio
de venta y pues no sé digamos si la
hipoteca original era de 500 mil bueno
de una casa de 500 mil este cuate
intenta vender su casa en 450 mil y eso
le paga el banco nada más entonces el
banco dice uno no sabes qué no o sea
realmente yo no te voy a dejar hacer eso
consigue el dinero o me pagas o
ejecutamos la hipoteca entonces el 4
dice ok no te pago entonces el banco
dice ok entonces regresa de la casa
ejecutamos la hipoteca todos dicen ok
pero el banco tomó una mala decisión
porque porque ahora
porque ahora en vez de venderle en 600
mil que hubiera sido lo inicial o en 450
que hubiera sido lo de la venta al
descubierto la subasta y ahora le va
súper mal ahora en vez de venderla en
600 mil nada más logra vender la 250 mil
en menos que la subasta anterior esto
puede parecer un poco extremo verdad que
de un millón pase a 250 mil pero no es
tan extremo o sea esto pasó en la crisis
inmobiliaria en eeuu en lugares como
modesto como miami como nevada como
arizona
esto está espantoso verdad porque ahora
todo el mundo se empieza a espantar dice
sabes que o sea que estoy haciendo que
tengo yo en la cabeza que estoy
trabajando tres trabajos o horas extra o
lo que sea para pagar un préstamo de 500
mil por un activo verdad que lo respalda
que únicamente vale 250 mil pesos ahora
si lo piensas tantito estos 250 mil que
no están tan alocados verdad sea nos
vamos para arriba
lo compramos en 100 mil pasaron y no sé
aquí ya pasaron 13 años o algo así llevó
a 250.000 entonces ajustando por la
inflación y por el crecimiento del pib
pues esto pudo haber llegado a 173 y fue
una buena inversión y fue una buena
inversión pero no tan buena como que
subiera a un millón de pesos más
entonces bueno es inversión shift si fue
buena pero en este momento la gente dice
sabes que ya no voy a seguir pagando
hasta que regrese a las llaves al banco
y ahora el banco dice china ahora yo
tengo una casa tengo que vender la tengo
que subastar la el banco una vez más
intenta subastar la verdad digamos que
ahora es la casa
este número 3 le regresan las llaves y
obtiene 250.000 y eso con cada una de
las casas de del condominio que pueden
ser cuatro o que pueden ser 400 vale
bueno entonces vamos a hacer las cuentas
de qué pasó con el dinero del banco pues
prestó 500 mil pero sólo obtuvo 250 mil
de regreso esto estaba mal y quizás un
poquito de intereses pero pensamos que
fueron 250.000 reservan con tuvo aquí
pérdidas y el dueño de la casa perdió
parte de su capital
verdad el dueño de la casa dos o tres ya
no se anima con lo cual dije que era
pero bueno el dueño de la casa perdió
parte de su capital pues vamos a hacer
cuentas de cuánto se perdió en total
pues a ver el banco y pidió este dinero
que es dinero real que pudo haber sido
invertido y en fábricas que pudo haber
sido invertido en investigación y
desarrollo en capacitar a personas esto
lo prestó en nada más obtuvo 250.000 de
regreso así que hay 250 mil en pérdidas
250 mil pesos en pérdidas verdad de
dinero que era capital que podría
invertirse en algo productivo pero que
no ya no apareció ahora vámonos acá
arriba a ver cómo le fue al dueño de la
casa el dueño de la casa pues tenía
tenía 20 mil verdad que había puesto de
enganche y además tenía una deuda de 80
pero su casa aumento de precios de 100
mil pasó ahora pasó ahora a 250.000
entonces si no hubiera realizado esta
transacción de acá ahora tendría 250 mil
en capital no los tiene entonces en
realidad perdió 250 mil pero los 250 mil
no eran totalmente
porque 80 estaban en deuda más o menos
haciendo las cuentas así medio
descuidadamente pero entonces
aproximadamente 250 menos 80 como 170
mil pesos 170 mil pesos se perdieron en
el capital de este cuate de acá
este cuate perdió 170 mil vamos a sumar
estas dos 250 con 170 nos da nos da
7 y 5 es 12 2 420 y 420 mil pesos
entonces en total hubo una pérdida de
riqueza de 420 mil pesos hay 420 mil
pesos que desaparecieron de la economía
bueno que desaparecieron de la economía
productiva no se esfumaron en realidad
de estos 420 mil se fueron al consumo de
acá va se hace fueron a cocinas de
mármol a baños a piso laminado y a
vacaciones que no son inversiones reales
no hacen que el pastel se vuelva más
grande para todos o sea las vacaciones
quizás un poquito si ayudan a sentirse
mejor es una pequeña inversión pero casi
todo lo de las vacaciones es un gasto
piso laminado gasto 2 baños gastos
cocinas de mármol gasto esto es acá son
bienes de lujo son bienes lujosos que sé
que después que se considera que se
deprecian a través del tiempo van a va a
bajar su valor quizás sólo da un poquito
de valor de que se vea mejor para ti y
para un prospecto comprador pero
realmente es dinero que está
desapareciendo no está siendo puesto a
trabajar en algo
productivo bueno pero todo el punto de
este vídeo era para explicar algo para
explicar esto de que a veces tenemos
ciertas burbujas financieras que
dependen de un cierto activo en este
caso las casas el mercado
correspondiente es el mercado
inmobiliario en el cual las personas
empiezan a subestimar el riesgo y creen
que ese activo va a subir y subir de
precio o sea la gente tiene una noción
inflada del precio de ese activo y
entonces empieza a pedir préstamos para
adquirirlo se apalanca o sea si le sale
bien su inversión pues le va muy bien y
le sale mal todo empieza a ir muy muy
muy mal en la economía en total sobre
todo cuando éste es generalizado qué
pasa a la riqueza queda mal ubicada y
finalmente cuando la gente se da cuenta
que estoy acá nada más es un sueño una
sombra y una ilusión entonces esto de
acá y esta riqueza queda totalmente
destruida al principio se siente bien
porque la gente dice ah pues tengo una
calidad de vida muy buena pero
eventualmente esta riqueza desaparece si
desaparece así totalmente qué pasa pasa
que el gobierno cree que puede alejar
esta destrucción de la riqueza o bien
desaparecerá ocultarla a través de leyes
su filosofía es más o menos la siguiente
dice mira si compramos esta deuda de acá
bueno la deuda no ya ejecutaron la
hipoteca pero dicen si compramos esta
casa de acá a lo mejor esta casa vuelva
aumentar su valor a un millón de pesos
la cosa es que puede ser que si no puede
ser que no puede ser que sí porque
aumentó muchísimo la demanda y el
salario mínimo y la gente pueda comprar
casas de un millón de pesos 400 casas de
un millón de pesos verdad pero puede ser
que no puede ser que este vecindario se
empiece a llenar de vagos o que empiecen
a romper los vidrios porque la casa está
abandonada que se metan las ardillas que
se metan las plantas que se descuiden
mucho y que se pierda totalmente esto de
acá entonces o sea el gobierno no puede
simplemente meterse y aparentar que la
riqueza no se ha destruido eso yo le
llamo legislar en contra de la realidad
y realmente como cualquier cosa que uno
hace en contra de la realidad es
dificilísimo o casi imposible ya sea
legislar contra la realidad o bien
hablar contra contra la realidad o
percibir un universo en contra de ella
cualquiera de esas cosas es difícil o
casi imposible sin embargo no quiero
sonar como una persona así súper
pesimista que cree que nunca
se va a salir de esta crisis
inmobiliaria en eeuu sea realmente yo
pienso que si hay una solución y eso te
quiero platicar en el siguiente vídeo
quiero proponerte una solución que me
contó un amigo y realmente tiene o sea
ya no penséis si tiene mucho sentido
claro tiene sentido siempre y cuando
pienses que el congelamiento de crédito
es el corazón del problema